hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to corpse party where
we last left off we found out more about
the story of this game and that there
are two sides to this crazy lady in red
and usually a lady in row be careful
this is something Satoshi will need it's
supposed to be placed somewhere acquired
marble statue you
well then I'm Oh what is this human
bones looks like it but I thought it was
a marble statue okay so I'm supposed to
be able to give this a whole touji so
I'm assuming that I'm gonna meet them up
there again because I'm gonna need to
talk to them and at them and throw them
things and trade around so they need to
place stuff and I need to not die so
that's just a general rule that I'm
gonna try to follow no no no no wait a
minute of this is right yes must be
right this is the way to go sorry I mean
I've been playing this all in sequence
but for some reason I still don't
remember exactly where to go all the
time so bear with me as I wander in
circles over and over a day over and
over again and our friend he was okay
though she are you unarmed blah blah
blah where's fizz Kamiah come on come on
come on get to the important thing yes
way but you're not gonna like it but
didn't you just say you found the exit
hold on no kita we have something we're
supposed to give you for me what is it
yeah this is okay no way are you serious
yeah anyway we should split up again to
find her remains got it
got the marble statue so that we can go
and do the thing with the other thing in
the other area and then they can go
screw themselves because they could have
gotten out of here
and now they're all gonna die trying to
save their friends either that or we're
all gonna die okay so I'm looping
through my saves again I'm just gonna
keep looping so I always have a 15 save
backlog of areas that I've been before
just in case I do something bad I want
to be able to go back and fix it
although maybe you guys have already
said that I've done something
irreversibly bad because obviously I'm
recording this all in sequence I do not
know if I screw up I apologize if I do
screw up I do not mean to please don't
yell at me but either way I got a marble
statue so I'm assuming that I need to go
and solve this puzzle over here this one
over yonder way with a hallway extend it
out no once I was supposed to find more
marble statues and give them to him at
the same time I hate I would hate to
have to go all the way back again but
hey this is the way life is this is what
I do this is how I do things
stupidly bring it on corpse party when
the party gets started what is this
again a single error may kill someone
why who ah no let me look at the statute
first it's a white statue made from
human bones okay yes nothing seems to
happen
then look good marble statue has been
set in her hands okay I'll take that ah
Saito she felt a sharp pain run up his
arms big brother gosh al what the heck
was that are you all right I think so
but probably not don't scare me like
that big bro let's try the other one but
it's gonna be guest:we oh hey good
that looks alive wait a minute what do
you mean it seems like something goes in
his hand something is in his hands huh
what happened I don't know what happened
what the hell just happened
am I gonna die is that supposed to do
that I don't know what you want from me
game give me some input I want to help
you help me help me to help you maybe
maybe not okay that one doesn't have
anything what are you doing
you've like nothing to see I need to
find another marble statue somewhere I
think that's the idea but I don't know
who do it cuz I get hurt
oh my god I'm almost dead why okay I'm
gonna reload the other say because
obviously I was not supposed to do that
hah good thing that save loading is very
quick I mean obviously it's not exactly
complicated so let's put that in there
with the man statue in his arm all good
up in that neighborhood and seems like
something goes in his arm so I'm
assuming that's okay something goes into
his arms I need to find another marble
statue to putting the other one so I
guess they had a flip-flop over to the
other guys I'm assuming that now the
other guys have returned from the other
world they're gonna be able to do or not
look it's awesome more I love more Mors
my favorite type of thing okay so we did
good I think
who knows maybe having it in the Statue
of the female hands also did something
else but this seems good I feel good
about this this feels good it feels real
good oh good more bile my favorite but
evil spirit in the principal's office
hello evil spirit Oh save me save me I
don't think so
I don't wanna what's with this guy stop
it stop it it wasn't my fault I didn't
kill you stuff torture hey filled with
such anger oh hi Hey
how disgusting how wretched it's all you
self-absorbed adults fault how about I
break you until you can't give any more
empty apologies please forgive me I
can't take it anymore yeah yeah you fool
you foolish fool ouch you think you can
apologize for what you did you PI
pathetic puke stain I will torment you
for all eternity southern boy
please stop pretty morbid goodness stop
it stop it right there young lady
stop what isn't he telling you to stop
you twerp what gives you the right to
tell me what to do I'll torment him as I
please how about this one-time offer you
leave and I'll let you live well no no
I'll force you to listen I'll make you
listen good thing to talk to the ghost
girl that's trapping you how nice the
tiny worms think the Giants I'll kill
you all with my bile I don't think words
gonna work so don't see we need to run
now okay running yeah huh oh boy you've
managed to really piss me off I'll have
to do something special for you oh boy
ah okay cool it's pointless it's like
all that existed was hatred Big Brother
do you think we can really go back home
no way we can win against something like
that so let's go back in there and see
what we can do to convince her to let us
out
hello again friend how we doing there's
no left on a desk ooh I should write
this down it seems important uh paper
over here is okay I - aye aye - aye cake
Sampras and to the three and then at the
bottom is the four and then the five
over on the other side cool got it what
is that gonna do for me you find a shiny
blood red embryo statue inside cool I
guess that's for the woman lady but why
whoa I get it so the woman's the only
role is to have the babies or embryos
gosh what a sexist backwards world this
is this is a cannon okay I was worried
about the change in music there whatever
the music just dies out
I get significantly worried that I'm
about to all
and the music just died out but it does
that here I know that happens here it's
not something I need to worry about I'm
just gonna overwrite this one cuz it's
practically the same I thought I'm I'm
going here and then put the embryo
statue into the hole even though the
marble statue was placed earlier is now
rolling on the floor Lukie oh good I'm
glad you want no where's the embryos
that's you place the marble statue Oh
God
hey we're good bye okay did you just
slice your way through me I don't know
what's going on there's also knows is
happening outside I don't know if my own
small golden key that's gonna be handy
and useful I got a small going key good
for me I think this is a piano key we
have one like this at home oh yeah
remember you own a piano
what is that illegal
oh that's obsess I hear Naomi not at all
it's kind of surprising Cantor players
are so sexy
let's go Yuka okay come on wait what
wait what what no why now you're
ignoring me what why what the hell just
happened there he's playing the piano so
unlike me what does that have to do with
anything
it's just play the piano I don't get it
why are they upset with each other can't
we all just get along
kumbaya and all that crap okay whatever
I'm just gonna carry on like nothing bad
happened I don't know why it bothered
with the marble statue being rolling on
the floor like that I mean obviously I
was just gonna pick it up and put it the
same place and then as sell is something
else I could have done that would have
been very interesting if I had swapped
the locations I don't know and frankly I
don't want to know you're gonna say
something to me yeah you better keep on
steppin I can actually go this way now
thank you don't know I couldn't before a
piano why would anyone put a piano here
unfasten piano a small gold key think I
should play a bit yes
no you
they're crappy things you know how
didn't we just go over this you don't
believe me I said I own a piano what the
Naomi started to play the piano that's
beautiful
what a lovely soundscape you are
creating whoa you brought all the
spirits about huh yeah don't tell me
these are all are they souls of who
those who died here no way that's awful
it's a lot of people too Oh are they
guiding us walk down the path I think
they're trying to help us let's go
follow me I'm gonna walk on the
nothingness we look at me go big brother
way for us and then oh we're swapping
okay cool so now that these guys are
back in the world I'm assuming that
they're gonna have some options you can
no longer return thanks thanks for that
now what do I do though okay so I'm
assuming I need to get back to some
general area that I wasn't able to go
before it was a security room where I
wasn't able to go in and then there was
the room to the south of that in the
basement where I may not have been able
to go see door appears to be locked door
appears to be lock I'm assuming if I
just go back to the other place the
other party has lost consciousness why
they just were guided by the ghosts one
of the ghosts do to kill them are they
all dead they're all dead aren't they
they're very dead okay maybe I can go
through this way now Hey look there's a
floor in the hole or whatever you know
what I mean it's late I'm very tired
ignore me everybody okay okay so what I
need to do is I need to read this first
four steps to the right thank you
seems like someone has been writing
letters and then you go what now brown
cow after that you need to hold on the
ribbon
gosh darn it dang it okay four steps to
the right maybe I needed oh there we go
got it
bass here's the incinerator it's
dangerous so I ask students not to enter
well good thing all that bile is
blocking the way because that's really
gonna discourage people hello welcome to
the incinerator no God know what I mean
oh this is the order that I'm supposed
to press okay please return the key
after use so does this have anything to
do with this symbol that I wrote down
there seems to be a nail jutting out to
hang a key on but the key is missing so
one two one three four five maybe I
don't know maybe this has something
nothing to do with what uh-oh
here take this with you are you the good
one or the bad one quiet security guard
key I can go in the security room now I
know you have no choice but hang in
there hang in there bro you're doing
great kid just slap on the button carry
on your way it's an incinerators pure
black with sit inside okie dokie so I'm
gonna go to the security room the
security room as people would want me to
say okay so gotta go this way oh no I
need to go okay nope go this way this
way cuz it's gonna send me back no with
it great the width Oh No hello how do I
go home now No Oh God Oh what's
happening how am I gonna get out good
oh come on oh god am I stuck here
forever
boo let's get me drew what do we do oh
god oh god please guess it off okay
thank you
and then I go whoosh I thank you can't
believe I almost got bested by that
incredibly difficult puzzle there okay
get out of my way you spirit I was
looking at my hands themself in the
webcam boy am I ever have cam them
terribly
terrifically ugly horrifically so I
scare children in the park I'm basically
the Hunchback of Notre Dame
okay security guard key we're too old
God is dark there should be a light
switch on the wall which wall okay that
was a mistake this is gonna be in badly
isn't it on which wall which wall which
wall friend so dark to see too dark to
see
feels like a switch Pookie lane so bad I
thought I was gonna be pad open the
drawer
oh I got a yellow ribbon so I'm supposed
to hold that ribbon on to something and
then do something else with it so that's
cool it's an abnormal amount of hair is
crammed inside the bookshelf I think any
amount of hair would be abnormal uh you
can see small insects crawling all over
it that's good okay this number five
god damn it where's number five I
haven't been able to see number five
ribbon what ribbon you mean ours that's
right with your yellow ribbon in MA but
we'll be able to get through this
together
yes uses a year D gaggy oh this isn't
gonna end well I know this isn't gonna
end well
why didn't work oh good we'll go back
now
look it's very dark very dark
there we go good guy sees the only point
of that just to make me feel uneasy
it's number eight god where is number
five hands stick it in the incinerator
boogie sounded good to me
I'll do that yeah but isn't that
dangerous yeah it is but it's what we
have to do why
how many other groups of friends didn't
make it through this sumbitch place
don't know but hopefully that are all
still alive and kicking but most likely
all dead seems like someone dropped to
scrap the paper there's letter five
goddamn about time after that leftmost
Center then checking from right and
finally okay I got to write this down
Jesus okay leftmost so I'm just gonna
dolly this up on a little thingy here
okay so the second one is the leftmost
so it's true and then the center is
third one second from the right is
fourth then second from the left is
fifth okay so I'm assuming that means
the one all the way on the right is
number one I think that's what the other
note said I just want to confirm sorry
Anita drink of water I've been recording
a lot and takes a lot out of you what
about this one number nine what just
happened
like I said Zaki from class two that
suddenly appeared oh you mean that girl
who went missing a year ago what someone
got out oh there's also letter tenor
told hurt you her name huh her body it
was burnt up oh oh my goodness I'm
asking you who she is did you get her
name you really want to know yeah yeah
it was class soon and she don't know
that's one of the names of the people in
here
no okie thought the life was going on
okay this was is really quiet don't know
what that did but okay very confessed oh
man I'm gonna and I'm gonna I'm gonna
get out of here I don't think I need to
be there anymore huh that room gave me
the heebie-jeebies ANCA I kept expecting
something to actually happen out of that
okay so I need to go find letter number
six again just to confirm that I am NOT
going crazy and I dunno what I'm doing
because that's how I usually feel about
my life but sometimes not so much
this one uh nope
that's a negative on that one rubber
ducky letter sinks um bum bum you hold
on to the end of the ribbon and god
dammit woman was it I I'm pretty sure it
was the one all the way to the right
that's what it was so so it's all the
way on the right first
okay Roger that rubber ducky do I need
to put on the yellow ribbon first okay
fine be that way waiting is that the
right one I don't know if that's the
right one okay that is press that one
okay but oh but oh press the number 2
all the way over here
motto boop press the number three in the
middle motto
Boop where's number four over yeah
bottle Boop
and then bow boop boop boop yay is that
a confirmation thing is that a good doo
doo doo be oh please return the key yeah
thank you I'm gonna put that key up okay
apparently I'm not nevermind now
yes you still owe yellow ribbon and then
stick your hand inside throw the yellow
ribbon and no wrap it around your hand
then sticker hold your hand out and
enter the incinerator but did you put
the ribbon on hey let me double check
there we go okay now we're getting
somewhere
thank you thank you the other ones will
head to my desk
I do pay attention
good thank you for opening the
passageway for me so go back why why
keep going no why why do I need to stop
if a voice in my head tells me to stop
and go back I'm pretty much assuming
that there's an important reason for
that and I need to stop and go back why
do I need to stop and go back now tell
me some game now zalim is almond and
something alright some not right here
why do I need to stop and go back why
why get out of my way spirit I need to
go in there why do I need to go back for
what purpose what what purpose what
purpose Raney go back were you a big
stupid poopoo head I don't get it
little kitty what do we need to go back
he's not gonna explain it to me you know
when I'm just as a test I'm gonna move
forward I gotta save so I won't be the
end of the world if something bad
happens but it may be totally
game-changing and I don't know you fill
me with in certainty oh god damn it I
gotta do the whole damn thing again oh
okay open the back up now it's the voice
in my head told me to stop and go back I
don't know why I don't think that
there's I do turn back why your evil
malevolent spirits I'll leave go away
no I hate everybody
I said no so dark and good well good
maybe you should turn on a space heater
or hear yourself up with all your fiery
burning spiritless okay what happened
you idiots
why do you persevere I don't know her
dumb you keep going despite my warnings
yeah bye-bye
something did bump somewhere I don't
know the 11 Mac Mac Mac man was ice wait
a minute what the hell happened Oh God
sistahs I look fun wait a minute
Oh No did they die what happened they
all dead
what happened no what happened oh my god
are they all dead
no they can't be today's just something
wrong did I really seriously did I do
something wrong here I what happened
wait a minute that's where they were was
what is happening you look so confused
what huh ah what are you looking at
what's going on I'm so confused
did I do something wrong I don't know I
don't know I do not know hmm oh hi hello
Yoshiki shinozaki are you all right
Makeda ah screw that did you find that
damn body yet no but somehow I can feel
it it's definitely close how can you
feel it weird oh wait a minute what the
Big Brother Yuka what's up big brother
my head has been aching since earlier oh
yeah Yuka Big Brother it hurts it feels
of me a head is splitting wide open oh
you can what's wrong oh it hurts oh boy
hold me be brother hang in there you
come right here I'm right next to you
except the one character away you're you
phantasmal specs know your place go back
who's there what do you plan to do with
my body dig it up and show it off like
it's some trophy how dare you your death
shall be blood covered that's very
sinister we must move forward we've come
this far what will going back prove
oh how surprising the dumb eights don't
understand speech how about this I'll
share with you my recipe cat hair all
abode titi be sure to watch carefully as
this girl's skin is marinated our own
Bryant issue no no stopping Oh God I
won't let you kill them what's the other
half to showdown yeah take that
okey-dokey huh you cur
hey brother are you okay
well then what the hell happened I think
so what's that I think I can feel her
presence she saved us
she saved Yuka but I think that girl
took great pains to even do that much
Yoshiki are you me you it's that girl's
spirit are you okay I'm sorry
her power has grown too great I can't
stand her can't stand against her any
longer that's why before I disappear oh
no is she going away forever that's bad
I pass my strength unto you
dot dot no matter what you all must keep
living oh that's our cuz she killed her
other half the girls presence is faded
the group can feel power surging inside
them loose in my veins and my loins oh
that ain't good
that's a thumpy all right we got this
yeah yeah we got it I think we all
together is one enosis me why such as me
you said we got this you're alone
alright bring it on oh now we're all
here it's dead end under the floorboards
there we go good oh did we fall oh boy
we're on nothing that's good that's all
good that's real good right there oh boy
what's that oh yeah what is that oh did
we just enter another level of Hell here
I think we did holy crap ow
oh is that us falling the floor was
rotted speaking of rotted what is that
smell
I think it's like doom and everything is
made of flesh are you all right Satoshi
oh I'm all right
I feel something strained on this floor
it's all sticky yeah I'm pretty sure
that's because it's basically raw meat
all over the floor no let's stay here
for a second maybe there's something
else that I missed I don't know if it's
like the other RPG horror games and I'm
supposed to talk to everyone so
regularly but either way I think this
part has come to a good closing point so
I'm gonna stop it here and continue it
right away so expect another part
tomorrow so thank you again everybody so
much for watching this is getting very
interesting I very much like this so I
hope you're all enjoying it as much as I
am and I feel like I'm not screwing up
that much which is really good so thanks
for being patient with me guys so thanks
again click the annotation more videos
games that I played in the past and as
I will see you in the next video
oh boy
good job
ah no
I knew it I knew
who